folks this is Joe D R Roa and I am
hitting that big Open Road in the year
2024 with my new hour I Never Promised
You a Rose Garden where's it kicking off
well it's kicking off right here in New
York City at the grar C theater on
January 13th January 19th and 20th I
will be at the comedy Mothership four
shows uh doing my thing in Austin Texas
February 8th we got Nashville at
basement East February 9th Charlotte at
the underground February 15th San Fran
at the Swedish American Hall folks I
then go on February 16th to Hollywood
San Diego on the 17th then in March we
got Palmdale California Portland Oregon
uh Seattle Washington we're adding more
dates every day also reschedules for the
dates I just had to cancel are coming up
so keep your eye out anyway you want
tickets you want show info go to jodor
rosa.com that's jod rosa.com for all
info and ticket links and of course as
always if you're in New York City come
on down to Joey roses we got a new
website Joey roses.com all the info you
need is there come have a sandwich and a
drink and we'll see you soon taste bus
they com to the mic talking about the
food they hate talking about the food
they like two fools going to fight but
only one food can be right taste buds
man yeah they coming to The Taste Buds
they coming to the mic talking about the
food they hate talking about the food
they like two fools going to fight but
only one food can be right taste buds
man yeah they coming to them hey Tasties
welcome to t a s t e buds sad when you
got to do the champ by yourself s's not
here s's shooting is special he'll be
back soon I think we got one or two
more uh where he's gone because of his
tour and his
taping uh and then we will be back in
action in the new year or maybe even as
soon as December I'm not sure with uh
some fresh new EPS with the boys being
back but in the
meantime I've got a wonderful special
guest host here with me today oh my
guest host all right or guest yeah I I
will be guest host then I want payment
no no I'll be steering the
ship Todd Barry ladies and
gentlemen what's up everyone you might
be one of the only guys where I I think
I can
name oh I think I I have a good shot at
naming every one of your albums and
specials really can I try yeah I
hopefully I'll remember Bill Burr used
to say you had the best titles in the
business oh really yes he did he never
he used to say it he's he's he's rced
Tod who he did pay for my special so
that's yeah no he he always said that
you had the best titles in the business
ready yeah medium energy boom falling
off the bone boom from Heaven boom which
was my that's from Heaven as a contender
for my one of my that that's up there
with favorite album titles ever oh wow
thanks oh album titles okay thank you no
the album itself was left a lot to be
desired but the
title no it's a great album it's
probably my favorite of your records
from that period or whatever but but no
from Heaven okay that's an incredible
title um hot spicy honey oh he blew it
sweet spicy honey no no spicy honey oh
just spicy honey spicy Honey's special
yeah and you missed one wait wait wait
domestic short here's the new one yeah
which plug it yeah it's your new one on
all things comedy on YouTube yes yeah
congrats thank you uh and there's I
missed
one you missed well yeah you missed two
actually an album and a special didn't I
you miss well there's some their albums
and specials there's the crowd work one
the crowd work tour that's one you
missed and okay well I just got it you
did get it you did get it all right you
didn't miss it okay and now what am I
missing now an album or a special or or
is it a a duel it's a it's a
duel it's your Comedy Central hour
yeah get get I'm serious give me a hint
because I think I can get this
[Music]
oo davel it was called
davel wait no no no that's not wait I
know that I get that that's a hint but
I'm not getting the hint give me a
better
hint
wow surprised shock and awe no shock and
a uh you want me to just tell you no no
I want to guess this you want to guess
this give me another give me a verbal
hint not a noise hint um it's a way of
describing someone who does who has
mental
illness crazy clown crazy person crazy
is in there oh oh oh crazy as a fox no
no no no still crazy after all these
years no that's I think that's a Paul
Simon album I know but I felt like that
would be a funny thing for you to I know
to just call my all right i' give it St
no something crazy it's two words
something crazy yeah but not stir crazy
no super crazy God that's my least
favorite of the titles though also so
I'm glad you forgot that one super crazy
I think super crazy is a good for you
it's a funny title yeah I know but it's
not it's not my favorite but it's fine
is that the one that ends I believe it
is I'm a fan Tod I no I'm I'm flattered
I looked up to you before I met you and
you got to know me like G before we
spent time interacting once you got to
know your
hero no uh the that special ends
with the thing
about um when a friend cancels PL yeah
yeah wow damn one of my favorite Todd
brry jokes friend cancels plans uh I'll
let you know if anything changes sorry
I'll be busy cartwheeling through the
streets something along those that's a
something like that right that's a
paraphrasing um you did also you left
out two Comedy Central half hours but
those don't have titles I have two of
those do you really nobody's impressed
by that
anymore what's up I would G we're
sitting I know I'm sitting here two of
them I have two of them wow me
you we're in a we're in a weird Elite
group yeah this is like when they'll be
like the first ever 33% hearing
impaired Asian man has been nominated
for an Oscar they narrow it down like so
far and you're like all right that's a
real small group there um we're in a
very weird small minority group uh that
can claim they had two yeah Comedy
Central half hours you me I think I
think Ted had two perhaps yeah uh I
think Lewis Black had two and I think
Carlos menia had to really I was on Ted
one of Ted specials did you see the one
where he brought out like surprise
guests to do rappers always bring out
their friends Canadians can't do that
and then you and Russ out yes still get
residuals for that occasionally
it was like 30 years ago I
think um I yeah no two uh I uh that
special with the cartwheeling through
the streets this was the other
compliment I was going to give you got
one of my other favorite I can't
actually I don't know if this is the
same special is that the one where you
open with the bti about he's
boundaryless oh I don't remember which
special that's on but uh yeah the one
where I went to Sweden that's a great
joke that's pretty good joke yeah thank
you yeah I should have just said Thank
you instead of agreeing with
you that's a how to how to not take a
compliment now name my special I I I
barely I don't even know your first name
I know you couldn't even name this
podcast you're on right now um let me
think if there's anything I know about
you probably not taste buds you have a
podcast called taste buds that is true
which I to be on by the way half of it
is happening right now the other half's
not here sorry you looked real disapp
pointed when you found out I was just
thinking you know like oh is it going to
be like you know when I did Letterman
and and John mackenro hosted you know
right right well this is like if you did
Letterman and just pauler there yeah
yeah nothing against John mackenro by
the way nothing against Paul schaer no
definitely not yeah I met Paul Schaefer
once yeah I met him in the street at on
Restaurant Row in Hell's Kitchen yeah uh
with Martin Short oh really and Martin
Short was they were smoking sming a
cigarettes I was shocked to see Martin
schw smoking a cigarette did you say hi
to them I was on a date I was on a first
date and I said to my date oh my God
that's Martin schwar and Paul Schaefer
and she said super cool and I said
Martin schwar has a show right now
called Jimmy Glick Prime Time Glick and
I go it's the funniest thing I've ever
seen is that character and I said and
she goes say something and I go no way I
feel too stupid like I felt I was like
he's Martin this is crazy he's like
and she's like oh shut up and she walked
up to Martin no but it it was it worked
out I I I you know embraced and she went
up to Martin Short and she said um Mr
short this is my date his name is Joe he
is a comedian here in New York City he
has something he would like to say you
oh my God it would have been great if I
went you're a disgrace to this you know
uh and I go uh I go I'm I'm embarrassed
I'm sorry I won't take any too much of
your time I just jimy Glicks man you're
you're you're the best jimy glick's the
funniest thing ever yeah and he goes
thank you very much in the jimy Glick
voice oh really how cool is that that's
cool yeah very cool and we just I said
okay and he went have a good night he
was very he was so gracious yeah and
Paul shiver was very nice too yeah he's
he is nice yeah um did you see the the
video of me not turn it back to me but
when I was on letter when I was on by
the way your next special turn it back
to me good Todd Barry title uh did you
see the thing this has been on number
where I was on Letterman when I was 18
have you ever seen this I don't think so
you never seen are you a standup on it
you're not this is from 1982 so you're
just you wrote him a letter yeah here's
this can you read read the letter you
wrote well you got to see the whole you
got to see the clip it's not well just
read the letter it's a clip about where
he shows a letter but it it's it's more
to it than that all right so you're not
going to read the I'm not going to read
it because it's so much it's it's
killing it it would kill it too this is
funny though I'm I'm reading the letter
not out loud of course but it's funnier
what Letterman says and then he calls me
and I'm on the air with him so you don't
we don't see you in this no but I was 18
years old so that's why it's amazing can
I curse yeah of course I can yeah
they'll bleep it okay uh we bleep the
curses do you really we do yes why is
that yeah really yeah does that you
think that boosts the numbers a little
bit it absolutely boosts does it really
it absolutely makes us more money okay
does it really yes well
dagnabit I mean we're arguing about
French fries there's no need for course
language mofo french fries um but people
can watch that clip do you sound like
Todd Barry in the clip I'm a I mean I
was kind of a wise ass to him when I was
I eight when I was 18 years old we're
talking 40 I'm not shocked you're a wise
ass now I know well I mean this is it's
just kind of cool that not to maybe you
should be saying this instead of me but
it's kind of cool that I was on the show
when I was in high school and then ended
up doing standup on the show was a comic
did you tell him that when you did stand
up I tried to once and I I just didn't
never I didn't you know you're not
there's not a lot of chatter with him
I've never met him he seems like an very
int he see then he seems like a very
intimidating man I feel like if you met
Dave Letterman now like Whitebeard Moses
Dave Letterman I feel like he now seems
like the most approachable man on planet
Earth I think he probably was I mean I
don't know what he's like during the
talk show he did not seem like an
approachable guy well I mean he didn't
even you didn't even meet him really
unless you sat down at panel like he
didn't come back he didn't do like what
Fallon does or Conan does well he does
stuff to like I've seen him with guests
where like he'll be like this with
Leslie neelen lesle neelson used to do
the thing where he brought the uh he had
the fart keychain uhuh and he would like
he would like go on talk shows and hit
the fart noises like as a g it was so
dumb but it's funny yeah and he didn't
there's a clip I believe from Letterman
where he's doing it and Letterman's kind
of being like okay all right then okay
you know like he did it a little bit
with um when Arty was on and Arty was
telling those Bob uker stories yeah and
he was kind of being like okay Ry all
right man yeah you know like like so Sho
him down a little bit yeah yeah so I'm
like he just seems like a guy like
during the talk show like a like a very
noons guy even though he's very funny
you know but who know now he's very like
now I feel like he's in that September
of his years where it's like hey who
cares man I do interviews I there's no
pressure anymore you know he did
something that I liked when he moved to
that theater in CBS yeah he wouldn't let
any of the executives be in the room he
just made them watch it at a bar on a
feed good yeah yeah good if you have the
power to do that yeah that's I think
that's amazing it's it's a nice uh Fu to
them well yeah I bleep myself on that
there you go there you go self
bleeper what do you think of that as a
title you never got a cat did you
remember when I ran into you on the
street you going to get a cat three
years ago yes I do well we just talked
about when I was in high school we can
go three years yeah uh I do remember
that I was on a date that day too I was
excited like oh he's looking for a cat I
cuz I didn't never pegged you as someone
who'd want a cat no you've never pegged
me period Todd not to be dirty
but see there you go there's a little
coarse humor for it uh no I am not a cat
guy and uh in that time I was trying to
find a solution to my pet problem by not
being allowed to have a dog uh and I
thought about getting a cat uh why
couldn't you have a dog in your building
building while while and it was still
kind of covid I live in a cat only
building also annoys me the Prejudice of
it annoys me it really does I have never
I got no problem with cats yeah I'm more
of a dog guy but I got no problem with
cats but I will say this I have never in
my
life I I have I have encountered far
more places that need deep cleans
because of cat and catell
iing well I would have thought that too
and I'm sure that's got to be it
to some degree in some places but I will
say
this many places like my building I'm in
now won't let you have a dog and their
reason is is because they're afraid of
damage to the hallways they're afraid
like your dog will pee in the hallway I
mean I have a cat and I always feel like
because I I do a bit about it but my
previous building charged me $50 a month
as a pet fee it's like I don't know what
that covers because like any damage he's
doing is to my [__] right my couch is
destroyed right that doesn't affect the
building at all right right right yeah
and it's not like they're putting that
money aside for you right they're not
like hey there's here's we can explain
why we to it's like $50 do you want to
have a cat or do you want to I guess I
want to have a cat so here's your money
the uh um speaking of buildings
mhm you're uh another one of my favorite
Todd Barry jokes oh okay this is all
compliments you this is I know man I'm
going to have to try to muster up a
compliment for you it's
can you believe this nothing he's got
no
uh you're looking at the you're looking
at the apartment yeah you know who lives
across the street Sarah Jessica Parker
and you go oh finally for all my Sarah
Jessica Parker needs yeah that was
pretty fun
joke that's pretty funny joke man that's
a good one it's a great one yeah it's a
great one yeah I remember how are the
jokes in the new special how are they
they're not good no they're they're all
bad no they're pretty good I mean people
give me one tell me one one joke from
the special I feel like your demeanor on
stage and your demeanor in your life is
so is so identical that you could just
tell me a joke now it wouldd if you were
an Uber driver and you just said that to
me I'd be saying you can pull over here
and I that's what I was hoping would
happen but I also realized it's comic to
Comic um yeah tell folks let's talk
about our sponsor game time game time
game time game time helping you buy
those last minute tickets for your
favorite events uh with the best deals
humanly possible uh game time is
offering last minute tickets Flash Deals
Zone deals easy to find and buy tickets
of every kind to any event in your area
I'm talking theater shows I'm talking
comedy shows I'm talking sporting events
I'm talking concerts whatever it is
they've got killer last minute deals all
in prices views from your seats you can
see exactly what it's going to look like
when you sit sit down and their best
price guarantee game time has taken all
the guest work out of buying tickets all
in prices show you the total UPF front
so you know what you're getting and what
you're getting is a great deal before
you check out there's no hidden fees or
anything like that it's all just right
there in the price and you can buy
tickets in seconds with two Taps find
exclusive Flash Deals and sponsored
deals on tickets for football basketball
baseball concerts comedy theater and
more with Zone deals you pick the
section and Game Time pick the seats and
you get Big Time Savings anyway take the
guesswork out of buying tickets with
Game Time download the game time app
create an account and use code taste
buds for $20 off your first purchase
terms apply again create an account and
redeem code t a s Buu DS for $20 off
download game time today last minute
tickets lowest price guaranteed folks
give yourself the gift of insane savings
this holiday season with mint mod mobile
's best wireless deal of the Year mint
Mobile's always got great deals and this
is their best deal so it must be pretty
dang good right now when you switch to
Mint mobile and buy a a any three-month
plan any three-month plan you'll get
another three months for free do you
hear me that six months of Premium
wireless service for the price of three
mint mobile is letting you order and
activate from your home while you also
save tons of money on plans and uh it's
all starting at just 15 bucks a month
month when you purchase any three-month
plan mintmobile lets you order and
activate from home while saving tons on
phone plans starting at just $15 a month
when you purchase a three-month plan
seriously this is just it's a great gift
it's a great gift and it's a great gift
for you or for a loved one or a friend
or whatever but what could be better
than taking these overpriced Wireless
bills and turning them into something
incredibly affordable like something
that's just $15 a month well mint mobile
is here to help you do that all right
also use your own phone with anyt mobile
plan and switch easily and effortlessly
with eim or if you need a new device for
a limited time you can get six months of
free service when you buy a selected
device and plan so for limited time buy
any three-month mint Mobile plan and get
three months free by going to
mintmobile.com
tastebuds again for a limited time by
any 3mon mintmobile plan and get three
more months free by going to
mintmobile.com
tastebuds that's mintmobile.com
tastebuds new customers only additional
taxes and fees and restrictions apply
cement mobile for details saying I
wouldn't ask I wouldn't ask like um like
bur I wouldn't go doke tell me one of
your new bits because it's like he'd
have to get up and it's all you know
what I mean it's because he'd give you
the answer that I should be giving you
which is telling you to f
there you go no I'm saying I'd love to
hear one of the new bits um can we just
play one sure are we allowed to do that
um let's see play the first one first
one yeah you look like Larry Miller in
that one picture but not in any other
picture
behind you and that that's fixed to the
wall does that always say Todd Barry on
it even when you're not there yeah I
think that's it just happened and we
found the place that already had my name
on a that's great I said I might as well
do it here right you actually made me
and you're not aware of this change the
cover of my first album did I yeah
I did a I used to have that show with
Jared Logan at um what was that Housing
Works uhuh remember that show yeah yeah
yeah we had that it was like every
Monday at the at that book was that your
show okay yeah well it was first it was
Pete Holmes and Jessie Klein show okay
yeah and then it was me and Pete and
then Pete moved to LA and it became me
and Jared Logan but uh but yeah it was
our show and
Emily um uh Jesus God Emily Emily come
Emily Emily Gordon Emily Gordon yeah
produced it and booked it yeah anyway um
we were doing the show and I we did an
album released for my very first ever
album which you don't know the name of
even though I knew the names of all your
things but I'm famous it was called the
depression auction yes I saw you in the
wrestler
the it was called the depression auction
but I had the cover up on the screen
yeah and it was a Terri it is a terrible
it was a terrible cover it's been
changed but it was me with with a for
some reason with a skeleton uh-huh
putting its arm around me
yeah here's why it was that here's why
that was the cover the original album
title was going to be it was going to be
called there's poison in the well was
going to be the name of the album and
the cover was supposed to be the
skeleton handing me a glass of
something and I was like you know like
like the gag like he drank it look what
happened to him not funny but that was
the idea at least and then we changed
the title so the picture of the skeleton
handl handing me the glass didn't make
sense anymore but all we had was
pictures of me with a skeleton so it was
still picture of me with a a picture of
me with a skeleton and I still looked
kind of like freaked out and we changed
the title but it's that was the cover
and it was on the back the big screen on
the wall and you came in and did a set
and you turned and looked at the screen
and you
said uh are you guys GNA Force Housing
Works to keep this up here all the
time and uh everybody laughed and I
immediately said I have to change the
cover of my album I can't do it cuz it
just came out but I will and a year
later I changed the cover why did you
change it cuz you were you made fun of
it's one of those things man you know
when somebody when somebody makes fun of
something in just right
way and it gets in your head oh now I
feel bad do you well I did I sure
whatever I was saying I was just busted
balls yeah but I'm glad I changed the
cover the cover now makes more sense the
cover now is me in bed like looking very
dejected rubbing my eye and it makes a
lot more sense it's the depression is in
the title know so um but
uh I try to find it that's okay it's on
like Spotify or apple music or whatever
but um my point is is you you the Dig
just it went in in just the right way
and I was like I got to change it and
that was it that was the old cover there
it is right there what a terrible
cover they superimposed a
gavel it's not their fault Comedy
Central did a nice job with all is that
the title that you kept the title is why
does that title not go with that it
looks like you're an Auctioneer that is
kind of what it became that's what we
doctored into being but the new title is
better there's a new or a new cover
excuse me can you find the other cover
yeah let's I'm going to see if I made a
mistake there's the new cover the blue
one
s that's much better okay that makes a
lot more
sense yeah depressing that's a sad
that's the one that's the winner that I
that is taken in Bill bur's apartment
that I used to rent you used to rent his
apartment I used to rent an apartment
from Bill Burr and that's the apartment
that I took that in the bed in that
apartment wow yeah that's cool lot of
magic made on that b oh I imagine I can
only I can only
imagine anyway uh
today we are battling Sal has changed
the wording I love
it I love that he changes the I love it
who changed it it's not hot left did
this wrong it's not hot leftover meal he
did the pole
wrong it's okay it's no it's not
actually that's not okay because the
whole point is that it's leftovers out
of the fridge versus the the meal fresh
I thought it was just the whole concept
of leftovers to begin with how about
that huh how about any leftover but not
hot the whole cool thing about leftovers
is that you eat them cold a lot of the
time yeah it shouldn't be we I can try
to change it now he shouldn't have
specified
hot V in 30 minutes if anything who who
in their right mind would vote for hot
leftover meal versus hot fresh meal yeah
that's good point this is completely we
can't this I'm on board with you for
once I agree with something you CH a
choice you've made you know what we're
Nick in the poll for this one we're just
going to discuss we don't need a PO
right yeah cuz that's that's just
incorrect I got my own opinions
regardless of what those people said I
love you know what and we're going to
change the title of the episode okay
this title is just going to be
leftovers really yes and you can say all
the stuff you hate about leftovers and
I'll talk about all the reasons
leftovers are great but this is just
going to be a leftovers episode starring
Todd Barry and myself so the original
thing
was um fresh food versus leftovers day
of food the idea being Thanksgiving is a
great example it's Thanksgiving time
sort of now right uh what do you like
better do you like that meal when you
sit down and your aunt or your nana or
your grandpa puts it out fresh and hot
or do you like that trip to the fridge 3
300 p.m. the next day and you make that
leftover sandwich that's the idea that
is I see I was so happy that was the
idea I'm not saying you got to like it I
was so happy when you said this was
going to be the battle because I'm
actually pass we can still battle we're
just
well I I don't necessarily need to
battle
you a
chant Todd's not the chanting
type what are we chanting battle battle
no Have You Ever Raised your voice yeah
I mean it's not
often I have never heard I'm sure you
could bring it out of me I don't I feel
if I lived with you I could bring
emotions out of you that you don't even
know in yeah yeah but I I speaking of
depression yes depression I could get
you to a lower energy I could get you
into a rage um we do a chant where we go
uh well there's two there's two that we
do there one is no matter what happens I
love you and that's the one we do to say
we're already kind of fired up we're
going to do this chant where we say no
matter what happens I love you
because it lets us know that no matter
how heated the B gets we're friends now
s and I had to start doing that because
the battles would get so heated that
sometimes we'd walk away a little cross
with each other seriously arguing over
like definitely now lers versus Skittles
that would get you fir we did one that
was weed versus alcohol and I like I
thought our friendship might end after
it wow yeah so um well if the I think
we're going to be fine doing talking
about leftovers yeah well you don't know
here's the other one see now now you're
you're very far in the other direction
which is we'll be okay so there's
another chant when it's meant to get
things a little fired up okay that one's
called it's time to get salty so we say
it's time to get salty three times we
chanted three times and then you fire an
insult immediately at the guy H I don't
I mean see you see I knew you wouldn't
want look at you I knew you wouldn't
want to do it I've I've feel like I've
insulted you 30 times
already
Yes this before the tape started rolling
I got you about like 12 times it's a
it's a real uh this is a real Dart you
fire yeah and the other guy is not
allowed to part the deal I'll do it no
you don't have to do it I as I said
before I explain the chants Todd is not
a chant kind of guy I'm perfectly happy
to just get into the topic you're
scoffing uh do you want to do the battle
chant with me sure I'll do that I feel
like you want me to do that no I don't I
don't I don't think that I do to be
honest time to b a l e buds say it again
CH time to b a t t l e buds that's a CH
that's the CH okay let's do it you know
for a guy that wanted to be on the show
you seem to know nothing about it I I've
listened to one episode I did listen to
one full episode which episode was that
the one I told you about the oh Theos
one Shake Shack versus um uh Burger King
Burg K with with uh AJ from entire
episode good kid really nice kid he
seemed like a nice kid yeah you know
he's never seen The Sopranos really
neither have I I didn't tell him that oh
you've never seen it I've watched three
episodes I don't like the show yeah he's
a great guy I'm sure everybody I've met
Edie Falco she's lovely yeah but I'm
just not a fan of the show I just never
was I made the mistake I mean I tried to
watch I watched like 10 episodes and
during the he of the pandemic and I felt
and someone pointed out I go like it
just wore me out man it's like every day
I don't want to see a guy getting his
head kicked in cuz he looked at someone
wrong right and then someone pointed out
and I think they made a good point I
forgot who it was but they said it's not
really a show that was meant to be
binged like you know what I mean it
wasn't you know it's like it was
originally I guess out once a week on
HBO I'm guessing yeah so you need a
little breathing room also uh my friend
Pat Walsh who I do another podcast with
called will see in Hell about movies
yeah he's a huge Sopranos fans his
favorite show of all time yeah and we've
argued a lot on the show about like I'm
not a fan of it he is whatever he
actually uh reframed it for me in a way
that made me go oh I think now I might
actually get it if I watched it but he
said he said I figured out what your
problem is with this show you're
watching it like it's supposed to be
like Good Fellas or something he goes
part of the Brilliance of the show is is
that it's supposed to be about guys that
are kind of low rent in the mob like
that are that are that are kind of
fuckups yeah and I never knew that so I
would always watch it and be
like I don't know like is this supposed
to be funny like I don't get like and
now now that one it's a very very simple
reframing but once he said that I was
like
oh okay it kind of makes a little more
sense to me now you know
so I guess we know what you'll be doing
tonight yes you be watch prize pick
prize pick prize pick is the largest
daily fantasy sports that's DFS platform
in North America the easiest and most
exciting way to play DFS it's just you
against the numbers not against other
people I like it you against the numbers
instead of battling thousands of other
players including pros and
sharks you pick more than or less than
on a two to six player stat projection
and watch the winnings roll in prize
picks is the most fun you're going to
have winning up to 25 times the money
this football season and now you can
play during basketball season two you
just select two or more players pick
more or less on their projected stats
okay and place your entry prize picks is
bringing your gifts early this year with
the 12 days of pikas 12 days of pikas
what's that starting December 14th there
will be a new promotion every day for
new and existing customers so it's
already started the daily promotions
will range from payout boosts to
discounted projections all right and
with basketball season here you can now
pick combo projections across football
and basketball from the specials League
a league created specifically for combo
projections than include two or more
players from different sports or leagues
that's cool for example LeBron James
plus uh another guy that doesn't play
basketball you know what I'm saying at a
10.5 combo of three points made plus the
other guys receptions let's say it was a
football player you get what I'm saying
uh also you want to bet alongside of
some of and with basketball season here
you can now pick combo projections
across football and basketball from the
specials League a league created
specifically for combo projections that
includes two or more players from
different sports or leagues for example
uh Lebron James who plays basketball uh
plus a guy that plays football uh at a
10.5 combo of three points made plus the
football guys receptions uh you want to
play alongside of some of priz pick's
most favorite players uh like rapper
Meek Mill and comedian Andrew Schultz
well you can now find Community plays
under the promos tab of the app and
that's going to allow you to view
entries of some of the biggest names in
the prize picks Community each week uh I
like prize picks for all the reasons I
have stated but mainly if you can tell
even by this ad read I'm not a guy that
really knows Sports and prize picks has
made it really fun for even a person
like me who I would go as far as to say
is sports ignorant to have fun with
daily fantasy sports it's fun I like the
combo thing it's just it's it's it's
it's a good time uh and it's quite
accessible and it's easy I also like
that you don't play against other people
anyway uh go to prize.com tastebuds and
use code taste buds for a first deposit
match up to $100 again go to prize.com
tastebuds and use code taste buds for a
first deposit match up to
$100 all right prize picks pick more
pick less it's that easy butcher
box ho butcher box oh ho ho oh butcher
box sending presents all year round but
now it's the holiday season it's really
getting good with butcher box it's
always good but it's getting extra good
butcher box has all you need for tasty
stress-free holiday seasoned with high
quality protein delivered to your door
you know what I'm saying here's my
here's here's here's what I'm saying you
want some peace in mind during the
holidays I know you do so why don't you
find the high Quality Meats and Seafoods
you can trust easily why don't you find
that 100% grass-fed beef or the
freerange organic chicken or the pork
that wasn't raised in a crate uh it was
raised CRP free and the seafood that is
actually wild caught humanely raised
stuff no antibiotics no added hormones
all right do you want that convenience
along with that do you want it delivered
straight to your door do you want free
shipping always do you want a curated
box or a customized box whatever you
prefer do you want incredible value
people do you want a variety of these
high quality cuts at an amazing value do
you want exclusive member deals do you
want recip inspiration and guides and
tips and hacks you want all of these
things and that's what butcher box is
bringing you do you understand sometimes
the best gifts are the ones also that
you give yourself butcher Bock is here
to help you treat yourself so you can
get everything I just mentioned Peace of
Mind ultimate convenience incredible
value why so you can have a tasty
stress-free holiday season that's what
they're going to do by sending you the
packages of the wholesome meats and the
wild caught fish and all that great good
stuff take the guest work out of finding
any of it and just enjoy yourself have
it brought to you conveniently
affordably eat deliciously healthily the
best way possible with butcherbox sign
up today at butcherbox.com tastebuds and
use code tastebuds you're going to get
free chicken wings for a year for the
love of God if it couldn't get it got
better it got
better three pounds of free range
chicken organic Wings every order that
you get for a year when you sign let me
say it one more time with every order
you get for a year there is going to be
three pounds of free range organic
chicken wings in there do you see how
good the people at butcherbox are so why
don't you go sign up where
butcherbox.com tastebuds and what are
you going to do you're going to use
promo code taste buds watch binge
watching 10 episodes and then
apologizing to yes all the people you
heard with that all the people I HT the
uh so I don't know but I've never I've
never been a big there's a lot of shows
like that I've never seen breaking bad
oh really that I I've never seen better
call S I was I've never seen it yeah
that's a great show I've seen three
episodes that's my compliment to you
you're very good on it and that's a
great show thank you very much I was
very happy to see you like oh [__] and I
was like kind of even a little jealous
actually that's good not an EV I'm glad
you took any anything nice about that
well this that is a compliment saying
I'm
jealous it's a weird that's what if I
said I'm jealous of that joke you wrote
you would be like oh that's really
flattering that's different though how's
it different man cuz the joke is like a
thing I created oh you create the part
well okay like like jeal like like like
that like saying I saw him in a movie I
was jealous it's like being like I saw
you hit the lottery I was a little
jealous about that I did compare it to
the lottery when I did see you in then
yes yeah um no I but I've never seen
that show really I've seen three
episodes from the the three times I went
to PR did you read the whole scripts
that you you weren w't allowed to oh
really oh that's that's as a lazy person
that'd be like oo oh I loved it they
just send you your scene and they're
like we can't show you anything else I
was like great
yeah Woody Allen used to I mean I've
heard he used to back in the day he if
he wanted you to be in his one of his
movies he'd send a messenger over give
you the script and he the guy would sit
outside while you read the script yeah
and then he'd grab it from yeah yeah I
mean look you know
you got to be protective of stuff
sometimes it's like you know like Star
Wars when they were making those new
Star Wars
sequels um they W they printed the
scripts on this
paper like that if you read it for
longer than like it was something like
if you read it for longer than 20
minutes or something your eyes would
hurt it's like a specially designed
paper that's funny so so that nobody
could steal a script from the set and
read it or copy it or anything like that
never heard about that yeah yeah it was
it was really it was it was on like red
paper that's designed to hurt your eyes
if you stare at it for too long I once
uh posted something I'm going to quote
one of my own tweets
now where I did Bob's Bergers and I said
I'm I'm G to leak part of the script I
probably shouldn't do this and it was
just picture of the word
the hilarious that is funny leftover
time that is funny that's pretty funny
you do that brand of yeah what's that
alt humor it's called no it's called
it's just called humor
it's called
gamer all right time to I'll do it by
myself time two b a t t l e buds that's
the champ okay I wouldn't do it I said I
would do it you kind of talk me out talk
me out of it all you ready you want to
do it yeah say it again then time to and
here's the Rhythm time to b a t t l e
buds okay ready yeah time to b a t t l
buds wow I've never heard your voice go
up that yeah man now I can't do shows
for two weeks now yeah that's the end of
it what are we going to do uh so all
right so so today's discussion is in
defense of or not in defense of
leftovers pimp however you want to title
this we could just call it leftovers we
can call it in in defense of leftovers
leftovers question mark leftover y or n
that is how I think we actually do title
it usually when we do this okay you
leftovers y oray um it was going to be a
poll s s put his own words into the poll
that changed it s didn't show up but
also ruined the
poll he's like hey I'm not only going to
not be there I know that was a double
negative I'm also G to up this mess up
this
poll I can't believe I'm on a podcast
where I have to be clean man I've never
heard you curse ever I curse all of a
sudden you're Mr
over try to keep it to a minimum just
for to make things not
cheap to make the honey spicy yeah you
get it there you go uh so why do you
hate leftovers so much I think you're
it's idiotic I find them
depressing and I find like like there's
just so many reasons and I'm going to
hopefully remember all of them like the
other day I was going to get some
routine blood work done and I got it and
then I was walking I saw this Chinese
restaurant I never seen before I was
like I'm going to go eat alone in a
Chinese restaurant I love doing that and
I ate it was like it wasn't a lunch
special so they gave me this kungpow
chicken it was like technically too much
more than I needed but then I was like I
keep eating it's spicy and it's like
what am I going to bring home like a
quarter of a plate of kungpow chicken
and throw it in a pan and so I just fck
pan I just shoved my f I just ate it all
cuz it's depressing man wait a minute
you're reheating
oh that's another thing C restaurant
Foods in a
pan yeah you know you have a microwave
you don't know cold it's just some my
microwave well that's not is is not
quite out of the box yet but anyway
that's a boring boring boring detail
it's not out of the box yet this new
apartment that I moved into didn't have
a microwave and I have one in my storage
unit which is like 11 blocks away by the
way I've heard that you have three
storage units I think I have four
but U let's not if you're going to say
stuff about me let it be
accurate why don't you just get one big
one I I know then then I think it I
think that's a good idea because then I
would see how ridiculous I am because
I'd have this or maybe it's time to move
out of the city and get a get more space
man if I had like a three-bedroom house
that would be it man everything into one
room
wrecked anyway go ahead sorry I mean
maybe the CH the kungpow chicken example
wasn't the ultimate but I just don't
like cold pizza is better than regular H
Pizza is no it isn't it's it's terrible
God you can't stop with the today all
right I'm going to try now it's okay
don't worry about it listen cold pizza
it's ter well no no it's not well hold
on hold on hold on this is where your
argument hits a hits a very flawed wall
all right here's where your argument
it's a very flawed wall some of what
you're saying is accurate but it is not
universal truth I will give you an
example uhhuh Fried Chicken
GH G what if you're going to say cold
Fried Chicken is better than hot Fried
Chicken it depends on what kind of fried
chicken you're talking about now like I
love KFC I love KFC oh I love KFC cold
KFC is awesome it's awesome hot KFC is
awesome yeah but both have their
qualities Pizza Hut is one of the types
of pizza now I know Pizza Hut isn't like
real Pizza whatever but you my point
I'll defend Pizza Hut I love Pizza Hut
yeah cold Pizza Hut is awesome no it is
if you get it with toppings it is cold
cheese pizza on I mean I could get it
down but I would never enjoy
it you don't like a cold Thanksgiving
sandwich oh that I find depre I find I
hate Thanksgiving to begin with why I
just don't I don't like the whole like
what are you doing for Thanksgiving what
are you doing for Thanksgiving oh I bet
I'm going to get on a plane you don't
like basic questions 800,000 people at
the
airport so I could drive six to fly 9
hours to eat you justest food drive to a
cousin's house an hour away what I did
do I went to the comedy Celler this year
God Almighty you're saying that the
other thing is depressing you went to
the comedy Celler for Thanksgiving yeah
was very few Comics there that's why it
was all right that is making it worse to
but it was um it was really fun and the
food was really good but I just like the
idea of they have wings turkey
sandwiches and with mayonnaise that's
the like the next the day after the day
after Thanksgiving is when stuff is open
again you don't have to have the same
Bland boring food you had the day before
What food did you eat on Thanksgiving at
the seller let me guess Israeli salad
nachos I say what' you eat I ate the
traditional stuff I ate the turkey and
the and the okay so they had the
traditional it was good it was really
good and and it was warm some people I
mean my dad are IP used to I think he
would I feel like the turkey was never
warm by the time we got it like he just
let it sit out well it sounds Todd like
it's a tech it's a you've had some bad
Thanksgiving preparations no no I don't
I don't know if it's I just it's fine
turkey's fine all right I don't want to
get too hung up on Turkey I okay but
let's say do you like ham I don't really
eat ham I've probably had in my life but
you've probably had I've never I've
never been like let's go make let's go
that's a strange thing to not ton that's
a okay but you don't like like you don't
like you don't enjoy like a dinner ham
like an Easter ham kind of thing I've
never that I've never I don't think had
or maybe tried a bite of that somewhere
but yeah that's sounds awful to me okay
well
uh uh meatballs do you like meatball I
like meatballs okay you don't like a
cold meatballs
cold what about meatloaf the next day on
some white bread meatloaf what about why
is it why are we eating this stuff cold
though I'm just saying there is a value
The Leftovers take on a new life they
take on a life of their own there is
[Music]
something or obviously like that
organically happens with the food uh
when it when it goes from I'm not using
the best words here but uh but there's a
transformation that happens when the
food goes from being piping hot to
sitting in the fridge overnight it has a
it has a uh an almost physical shift to
it uh and I think that there is
something really enjoyable about that
there's also something really just you
know George Carlin had that joke about
leftovers in the 80s about like you know
like the pro I'm really bastardizing
this joke but it was something along the
lines of like you know they're rewarding
because you get to eat but also like you
feel you feel like
um you know you're utilizing the food
again you know it's very satisfying
because you're not putting anything to
waste or whatever and there is that
there is that
element to leftovers that I really do
enjoy where it's like I get to I get to
take this I made this great meal like
you do you live alone yes you don't mind
me asking okay so I live alone do you
cook never it if the microwave is still
in the box that stove is probably still
wrapped in plastic I cook it's very hard
to cook the right amount of food for
cooking for one's a nightmare I'm going
to am I allowed to agree with you on
something yeah you can do whatever you
want so my point is is I like to cook
but I'm often cooking for one and it's I
like the next day or two days later
having some stuff left over sometimes I
combine the meals sometimes I'm going to
take the chicken from Monday the steak
from Tuesday and on Wednesday
I'm going to have like a a nice little
smorgus board style platter here you
know like uh that's the saddest
loneliest
smorgasport one plate of let's look at
this look at the spread here of one
plate
the steak is the steak is a food I will
agree with you on steak leftover sucks
usually usually what about what about
Chinese food dude Chinese food is the
king of Le overs Chinese food is the
greatest leftovers food of all time
that's the that's the most exciting part
of ordering Chinese food as you go all
right I'm spending 25 bucks now and I'm
going to have a second meal tomorrow
like like Chinese food with left you
okay yeah I'm all right you keep
coughing I've it's been dealt with I'm
fine all right all right it's not Co or
something like that no no no I mean it's
co but it's okay that's what I meant
when I dealt with new St I got
um but it's it's like China food um um
Mexican food is a food that I often have
leftovers with but but let's stick with
Chinese food dude there's nothing better
dude there's nothing better than Chinese
leftovers especially given the old
cliche which is true you're hungry an
hour later again you eat it you put it
in the fridge it gets a little chilly
you pull it out again around midnight
you don't like cold food around midnight
you don't you don't do the midnight
snack run to the fridge I I I clearly
don't do this
that's what what do you what do you what
do you eat so let me ask you this yeah
go ahead do you ever like you get
Chinese food what do you
get well I get all kinds of stuff my
favorite things ever though I love
Chinese I love the barbecued spare ribs
yeah those are good uh I love a general
s chicken I love the fried chicken wings
okay which is a very New York thing but
I love the fried chicken rings I love
the um oh and rolls of course yeah uh
and then I really like the um what's the
thin
noodle Ling no uh Lan no there's like
a there's like a um like an almost like
shoestring kind of Singapore noodles but
no
um there's there's low man then there's
Chow then there's May fun that's it
mayun thank you V uh I really like
getting the mayun noodles with like you
know shrimp and veg whatever the hell
you get in it um what do you like I like
uh I mean I like I go to like I think
semi-authentic sesan places sometimes
and there's there's one in the East
Village called Han Dynasty that's I know
Han Dynasty cumin chicken which is just
it's just so good yeah yeah it's just
chicken stir fried with a lot of [__] and
it's spicy and it's you know onions and
peppers and you should never serve it
cold and it's
just but my point is is you get let's
say you're
home you're not feeling too well yeah
you you you feel good enough to eat you
just don't feel good enough to leave the
house and you're real hungry you go you
hit that door Dash you have cumin
chicken delivered from Han Dynasty the
dish cost you
$23.99 but there's enough there clear
Lally for two people uhhuh you eat a
quarter of it cuz you're not feeling
great not even half of
it you're not excited about oh this dish
I love I can revisit in another day or
two if I did do it I would reheat it
well that's fine but that's still
leftovers yeah it's the it's the cold
thing that really is that bums me out
more than reheating leftovers right does
that change the whole tone of the show
now no no because I do think I do think
like a big key factor with
leftovers I I I think a defining quality
of leftovers is often the coldness of it
do you ever give your leftover food away
to someone yeah I do that all the time I
I will do it if I'm if I'm coming from
the restaurant with
it what do you
mean like if I'm coming from a
restaurant yeah with leftovers yeah I
mean doggy bag I'll try to give it away
to somebody or whatever right uh if it's
home home I usually end up eating it as
a means to not spend more money on more
food but I've actually packed up a bag
at home of stuff that I thought would be
better served for somebody else a that's
nice and tried to find somebody to give
it to it's hard to find someone when you
I know isn't that weird it's like trying
to find a pen when you're on the phone
will you uh you can never find it what
if you walk by like I bought a guy uh a
Five Guys the other day mhm a homeless
guy do you do that I've gone in yeah the
last when I did that I was outside of
popey's yeah I did I've done in front of
Popeyes and I was on a diet and I went
in and bought the guy Popeyes and I had
to forceed myself to not buy myself any
Popeyes and it was real tough and for
some reason that they I shouldn't say
this but they they they always follow
you in then they're like I I want nine
Burgers like all right like how about
we'll get you a couple burgers and
follow you complete stranger body really
I've never had a guy follow me in they
always stay outside and I go all right
I'll go I'll get you something I mean
sometimes they do but they want what
they want but it's like one you know
you're still I get a real attitude about
like if I'm trying to help you out and
then you start dictating to me now I'm
not saying like I don't mean that in a
demeaning like you'll take what you'll
get in your life I don't mean it like
that I just mean like dude there's
there's there's hey help me out and then
it that can sometimes cross into a place
of entitlement of like dude what are we
doing here I've gone in there was a guy
when I lived in La I lived near a
vau supermarket and there was a guy that
was always out front of the vs always
and he would always if if you walked
past him ask you to get him something
and dude I went in one
night I I I I did this guy right I got
him the the the like cuz he had
mentioned chocolate
milk so I got him like a gallon of
chocolate milk I got him like a huge sub
like a like a like a Cosby Show yeah sub
I got him like a you know the party bag
of chips damn I got him uh like some
kind of dessert thing like cakes or
something or other I can't
remember I brought him out dude it was
literally like in a full shopping bag
worth of food I go here you go buddy and
he
didn't say anything he didn't say thank
you he barely it was literally like like
if you were like approaching like
Britney for an autograph or something
you know it was like it was so
dismissive kind of want to thank you
even though the guy's probably mentally
ill and yes he shouldn't be Jud he yeah
he's sculpting with his own feces and
I'm like I can't get a thank you can't
believe this directly at me if you could
without covering your mouth I appreciate
that you're
right uh all right the anyway so um it
is but it is a little like some times
you're like dude look there New York is
this is a real problem in New York there
are guys in New York with like you're
like dude you're not homeless you're
like in fresh press clothing right now
and you're just this is like your hustle
you know and it feels terrible to to
insinuate that one should Window
Shop homeless people for authenticity
right but in New York it really is you
know the the the The Village Voice did a
huge story on it years ago about guys
that there was a guy that was like said
he put his kid through college uh uh
haggling for CH not I wonder if it's a
guy because I overheard a guy who's like
a regular who I've seen around from a
lot and he and I overheard him talk go
it's like a scam I make 90 bucks a day
or something like he was like yeah he
was kind of like had that kind of
attitude towards yeah it's uh it's
interesting it's interesting there was a
guy
that that used to come around on the
West Village who was very able-bodied
yeah very able-bodied yeah and then one
day was just in a wheelchair and there
was no sign of like oh is that the guy
who yells a lot I don't know if he ever
yelled okay there was no sign of like an
accident has happened or like he just
suddenly one day was in a wheelchair and
I was like I think I think he just got a
wheelchair cuz it'll help yeah the
hustle a little bit I think uh it was it
was a little suspect but maybe he found
a a wheelchair somewhere maybe I don't
think he was homeless though my point
but I've also have they ever done this
where like the guy's out front and he's
like hey you can you get me some food or
or maybe over here I'm saying asking
someone else for food say I'll go get
this guy some food and you come out and
they're
gone no no I've had that really I bought
a guy a Red
Bull he's sitting down in front of CVS
and he's asking people can you get me a
water Red Bull get this guy a Red Bull
that's easy
right walking around where's this dude
like with a red Bowl cuz I don't drink
Red Bowl and you're just like now I have
this dangling red bow which might still
be in my
refrigerator I'm never going to drinking
then you're just then you become like
you have a friend overhead you want you
want a Red
Bull please say yes you want a Red Bull
you're just trying to give it away your
cat sitter hey there's red in the
refrigerator you want videotape in the
ringe please take this yeah get this out
of here the uh the uh uh but wait a
minute but back just we're oh geez it's
already 51
minutes you know Todd time flies with
you I'll say we need to we need to lay
out some closing uh arguments real quick
about leftovers so uh uh here we go
leftovers they're depressing nothing
more depressing than seeing like when I
used to do jobs in offices or whatever
someone sitting at their desk with
Tupperware oh my God it's
depressing hot food should be eaten
hot for the most part unless it's beef
jerky I don't even like shrimp cocktail
wait a minute wait a wait what did you
just say about beef jerky beef jerk is
an example of food that you can eat at
room temperature that I approve of it's
supposed to be eaten at room temperature
exactly so you don't like anything cold
period I like iceam once you said you
wanted to come to my sandwich shop and I
said I said yeah I go okay and you go
and you you literally go you got
anything I'd like down there I I I don't
know Todd cuz I don't know what you like
and then you described a
sandwich that I would never ever put on
the menu ever was it the one I got in
Guatemala it was just like like grilled
chicken with barbecue sauce and yeah it
was something terrible like that
drooling thinking about that you like
will you add that to the menu call it
the Todd
no it'll be available one of one of
these will be available outside I'll do
an in store for free if you name a
sandwich after
me yeah you were like I'd like turkey
with lettuce no lettuce and I don't know
it just it was a just a [__]
sandwich and then I described you what
we did have and you looked like
horrified I was horrified cuz like oh
man I got this friend who owns a
restaurant I'm going to beaten free
forever and I was like I don't want any
what friend is that I know I as I said
friend I was like I don't know about
that TD plug your special man oh my
special is uh called domestic sh hair
it's on YouTube for free and if you want
to pay for it there's places where you
can pay for it right that's what that's
the climate these days like it's free
absolutely free or if you want to pay
for it you can pay for it on kind of
like leftovers in food you can get it
hotter you can have the so check it out
um
also I I'm on tour the half joking tour
if you want to check that out all right
tod.com also if you have any food that's
left over just give it to someone don't
eat it don't bring it home and like oh
look have cold food tomorrow I can't
wait I like this new character of yours
the the person that doesn't like the
things you like they all have that voice
I you should work it into the
ACT uh oh boy oh boy cut these coughs
out will you all right Todd brry taste
Buzz they coming to the mic talking
about the food they hate talking about
the food they like two fools going to
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man they coming to the folks
this is Joe de Roa and I am hitting that
big Open Road in the year 2024 with my
new hour I Never Promised You a Rose
Garden where's it kicking off well it's
kicking off right here in New York City
at the gramar theater on January 13th
January 19th and 20th I will be at the
comedy Mothership four shows uh doing my
thing in Austin Texas February 8th we
got Nashville at basement East February
9th Charlotte at the underground
February 15th San Fran at the Swedish
Amer Hall folks I then go on February
16th to Hollywood San Diego on the 17th
then in March we got Palmdale California
Portland Oregon uh Seattle Washington
we're adding more dates every day also
reschedules for the dates I just had to
cancel are coming up so keep your eye
out anyway you want tickets you want
show info go to jod rosa.com that's jod
rosa.com for all info and ticket links
and of course as always if you're in New
York City come on down to Joey roses we
got a new website Joey roses.com all the
info you need is there come have a
sandwich and a drink and we'll see you
soon taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools going
to fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man yeah they coming to